You are competing
with your lovely cast.
We'll see how I do.
This is the
Academy's 90 seconds.
So I'm gonna hit the timer.
OK.
And I'm gonna start
asking you questions.
All right.
You got this.
OK.
Let's just do it.
Whatever.
What movie does Robert De
Niro's famous line, "You talkin'
to me?" come from?
Taxi Driver.
Yes.
Rydell High School
is the setting
for which influential
70s musical movie?
Grease.
Yes.
How many total Grammys
did Aretha Franklin win?
13?
Julie Andrews won
the best actress
Oscar for which 1964 musical?
What do you call it?
When she was the nanny.
Yes.
Yeah.
OK we'll take it.
OK.
Mary Poppins.
Mary Poppins, right.
What song did Aretha sing in the
1980 film, The Blues Brothers?
Oh, "Think".
Yes.
Jodie Foster played FBI
agent Clarice Starling
in what 1991 film?
Silence of the Lambs.
Oh, you're doing great.
OK, what was the
first feature animated
movie released in history?
Snow White and Seven Dwarfs?
Yes.
OK, which 90s movie has
the best-selling soundtrack
of all time?
Has the best what?
Which 90s movie has
the best-selling soundtrack
of all time?
90s movie?
Oh, shit.
Can you give me another hint?
Is it a musical?
OK.
What is your favorite
Aretha Franklin song?
I think, "Think".
OK, we're going to
give you another try.
What is your favorite--
Oh, "Respect"?
Yes.
Boom.
There it is.